i wanted to transition into something
that we spoke about
before we got on
and
it kind of ties into the network thing
but brotherhood
versus guilt especially guilt when it
comes around society and particularly
women trying to
use guilt as a as
really one of the only tools that they
have you know they're not going to kick
your ass you know they can't fight you
they can take sex away
but if you are a high enough level man
they know that you can replace you know
or get other sex and that's kind of
taken away
uh and and then you have guilt
and guilt i think stands out really
large when it comes to brotherhood
because it's one of those things where
oh why do you live with sterling or why
would andrew and tristan live together
all people that have pretty high net
worth
and the only attack mechanism in that in
that situation is guilt and we were
talking about that before and i just i'm
very interested in what you think about
creating brotherhood in your life and
having
kind of
your guy six so the outside world can't
penetrate and you're not isolated yeah
um it's
not given enough value like i have my
own community um too as well and um you
know this year there's gonna be a big
big focus on
uh developing that community in such a
way that
the
elite level
members are essentially all going to be
anti-fragile right
so
i think i'd want to boil that point down
you know that brotherhood to
you want an anti-fragile life i mean you
want a life and you know that you can
live that when chaos comes at it when
when trauma comes at it when weird [ __ ]
comes at it
um you've got tools resources and you
got your boys in your inner circle that
got your back um
and if they don't then why are they in
your life you know like why would you
have a roommate that is trying to bang
your girl you know for example that you
got over or is like hitting on her in
the morning you know sort of thing or
like [ __ ] talking you know behind your
back when you're in the shower right you
wouldn't have a guy like that for a
roommate you get rid of the [ __ ] guy
or you move out right if you figure that
out pretty quick so
um
yeah like men need to test each other
and they need to hold each other
accountable
um
so most guys um you know to the question
of that of that shame and guilt that
women try to throw at you like oh you
know why don't you grow up and you know
get your own place why do you live with
a porn star sort of thing it's like
because i like it you know he's my boy
why don't you just flip it off basically
is the way that you got to handle it
right and it's like you know
those those kinds of relationships like
those kinds of friendships
are some of the most important that you
can develop as a guy most guys never get
to that point they don't have guys that
got their back they don't have guys that
are competent they don't have guys that
have combat skills they don't have guys
that have connections and resources and
know how to solve problems right
that's really important i mean if you
want to live a a great life as a guy if
you want to be as anti-fragile as as as
possible
um
you you need people like that in your
network and most dudes don't even
consider that like they'll like they'll
bawk at me that would be like oh you
charge x amount of dollars to enter your
community it's like yeah
well
can i do monthly installments no
because if you can't rub together the
money you're not a good fit dude you
know like
i welcome you back when you've got the
uh means to join in and you can pass you
know the test sort of thing but
no i'm not having it right like you know
like this is this is why i'm doing these
things and it's like
real real important you got to find a
tribe you know jack donovan i don't know
if you've read his books
i've not i know who he is yeah like if
you get into like the way of man and
becoming a barbarian like those are are
all important from the perspective of
you need
strong virtuous men in your inner circle
that can hold you accountable and that
got your back
really important
man i love that
um one thing that makes me think of is
i uh i paid to go to a certain seminar
this year and my ops manager asked me
she said justin don't you think you've
learned enough
and what i told her was
is i don't think you understand at some
point
you're paying to be in a room with
certain people yeah
because
is your net is your net worth right so
it's not just a learning event but it's
the people that end up in the room at
that learning event
right i have one goal i have one goal
when i go uh if i can go to a conference
or seminar or read a book or whatever it
is and i can learn or take away one
thing that i have my tool belt for life
worth it
but more importantly
if i can walk away with a contact for
life
then it pay for itself 10 times over
yeah a lot of people um you know because
i'm a big car guy i think you know that
you know they'll say ah you know why do
you spend so much money on a car it's
you know such a waste of money
blah blah blah you know they just
appreciate it's like throwing money down
the toilet blah blah it's like like not
only do i enjoy driving it and does it
and does it deliver a big smile on my
face i mean it's the most fun you can
have with your clothes on it you know at
the end of the day but i also get to
network with other men that can afford
that kind of car that'll have
interesting lives as well right so
you know i was talking to uh tristan
about a month or so ago i know he's one
of your boys and he was telling me about
the bugatti and i'm like yeah yeah you
know you know talk about the network
part of that he's like well that's why
we bought the car because now you can
get invitations to exclusive events that
bugatti hosts and now you're in a room
with people that can afford a 5 million
car
right it's not just about the car it's
not just about the badge it's also about
you know buying your way into a room and
a lot of dudes discount that like
they'll make fun of it they'll be like
oh you spend or or that's stupid or blah
blah it's like that's a that's a big
word salad for saying that you're broke
and that you don't want to do the work
right
right right and and that's another thing
guys will do just like women is if
you're doing something outside their
frame and they have any envy over it
they can come after you with guilt or
or something that makes you
makes you seem like you're you're in the
wrong fort there's a lot of feminized
guys today and all they do is they just
default to that program because they see
women do it they were raised in a single
mother household and they think that
they saw mom or their sister or their or
whoever point and sputter when they
didn't get their way and it's like we've
got this we've got this massive
like chunk of the population that loves
to embrace a victim mindset and it's
like you know what dudes i'll tell you
guys right now it's never been easier to
stand out from the crowd than it is
today there's
a lot of weak plusified men out there
that just want to play the victim card
and you know put [ __ ] up on a pedestal
and bend the knee to you know the the
female first primary social order sort
of thing and it's like
guys that stand out from that noise that
are doing the work that are strong that
are competent that have game that are
captivating that have an interesting
life all those things they're the ones
that stand out from the crowd right so i
mean you can point and sputter all you
want
i've seen what you praise i've seen what
you which you losers and you cry babies
praise
your your criticism means absolutely
nothing to me
yeah i completely agree with you
you